[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
So we've sort of
got into this place where
we can make anything
we want all the way to scale
the atom while at the same time,
we need that more than ever
to solve the most pressing
global challenges.
It's a really exciting
time to understand
how atoms come together and
what we can do with that.
SARAH HANSEN: Today on Chalk
Radio, we're talking atoms.
In this episode,
we're going to see
what it takes to bring
concepts from theory to reality
and how one professor
at MIT has learned
to make his course
content real, tangible,
and important to his students.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: If
you can touch and feel
some aspect of what
you're learning,
then you learn it
in a richer way.
You learn it from
a different angle.
You see the problem a
little bit differently.
SARAH HANSEN: We're
going to explore
the world of solid
state chemistry
course 3.091, which as
always is available on MIT
OpenCourseWare.
And to take us through, we're
talking with Professor Jeffrey
Grossman.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: I am the head
of the Department of Materials
Science and Engineering at MIT.
I teach 3.091, and I do
it as the lead instructor.
But it's only possible
to teach it effectively
because I have an
outstanding staff of TAs
as well as a wonderful
course administrator who
all come together.
And we give it our
all every fall.
So that's why the course works.
SARAH HANSEN: And this
course, like many others
we've highlighted
on our show, needs
a team that understands
how to speak and appeal
to a general audience, an
audience that may not know much
about chemistry to begin with.
This course is what we at MIT
call a GIR or General Institute
Requirement.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: Before a
student can graduate from MIT
with an undergraduate
degree, they
have to have taken one
semester of chemistry.
So we emphasize the basic
building blocks of chemistry,
and then we build
solids out of those.
And so the basic building blocks
are atoms and the way atoms
bond together and then how
those atoms come together
to make solid materials.
And that's why the
course that I teach
is called solid state chemistry.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: You've
probably heard of the Stone
Age and the Iron Age.
But what age are
we living in now?
Part of what makes this
course so interesting
and one of the reasons that
I wanted to share it with you
is that it invites you
to explore questions just
like this, questions that
take a contemporary look
at solid state chemistry.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: So as
a materials scientist
and engineer, I love
the fact that we
tend to name the age we live
in by the sort of material that
mattered most in that age.
I would say that recently,
we've had the age of silicon,
the age of plastics.
I think that we have reached a
time in science and engineering
where we will never be
able to do that again i.e.
to name the age we live in
by some single material.
And the reason is that
we are now at a place
where we can actually
design any material any way
we want all the way down to
the atoms that make it up.
And so that's a kind of new era.
And I call that the age
of materials design.
It's really the age of atomic
scale materials design.
There's a very famous
speech that Richard Feynman
gave called "There's Plenty
of Room at the Bottom."
And it was really
the first vision
of what would happen
if you could move atoms
around anywhere you wanted.
And, well, you could make
pretty much anything.
And so the question then
is how could you do that?
And then the other question
is what would you make?
SARAH HANSEN: And if that wasn't
enough to pique your interest,
Professor Grossman makes
sure to apply these questions
to the issues that affect
humanity on a global scale.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: What is
so exciting about the fact
that we now are
able to put atoms
anywhere we want, that has
come at a critical moment
in the challenge
that we face globally
in energy and climate
and sustainability
and many other challenges.
Because at the heart of
getting through and solving
these really hard problems lies
the design of a new material.
And so we've gotten
to this place where
we can make anything we want
all the way to scale the atom
while at the same time, we
need that more than ever
to solve the most pressing
global challenges.
It's a really exciting
time to understand
how atoms come together and
what we can do with that.
SARAH HANSEN: To
Professor Grossman,
the real world applications
of solid state chemistry
are just as important as
the theoretical concepts
so much so in fact that every
single lecture has an added
element that explains how
students can practically apply
the concepts in the real world.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN:
Just because I'm
teaching say a lecture
on the periodic table,
or I'm teaching a lecture
on Lewis structures,
on X-ray generation,
it doesn't mean I can't connect
in each case to some sort
of bigger picture
question or something
that they can really
connect to that
is more broadly accessible.
I call it my "Why this
Matters" moment because it
gives context.
And I think we as
teachers should
be able to do that with
anything we're teaching.
So for every single one of
the 36 lectures that I teach,
I take a "Why this
Matters" moment.
And I connect what it is
that we learned right there
in that lecture to some sort
of pressing global challenge,
or maybe it's a
technology that they all
know or can connect to
just to give that context.
SARAH HANSEN: And as
you may have guessed,
the "Why this
Matters" moments are
a favorite part of Professor
Grossman's lectures
and not just for the students.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: It's also
really important for me
because it makes me excited.
And it makes me
every year come up
with new ideas for how to relate
the material to some bigger
picture aspect of their lives.
In the first year, I
actually wound up sometimes
cutting that short.
Sometimes I had
too much material
to get through in a lecture.
And so we didn't get to
the "Why this Matters."
And what I heard
from students was
how that was such an
important part of each lecture
that they didn't want
me to ever cut it short.
And so I've been very protective
of those moments of class.
Because as soon as I put
the "Why this Matters"
moment in front of them, they
sit at the edge of their seats.
I feel that this is
something that we
could do in any class we teach.
I don't care if it's some
advanced algebra or a Python
programming class or
civil engineering.
It doesn't matter.
Every time we teach,
I think that we
can take what we're teaching.
And we can try to give
it some sort of context,
how what they've just learned
connects to something else.
SARAH HANSEN: At the heart of
Professor Grossman's teaching
is a focus on allowing his
students to see, touch,
and interact with
the subject matter,
to make it apparent
to the senses in order
to make it matter.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: I always feel
that if you can touch and feel
some aspect of what
you're learning, then
you learn it in a richer way.
You learn it from
a different angle.
You see the problem a
little bit differently.
So in the very first
lecture, in fact,
in the introductory
lecture, I talk
about how it is that
chemistry came to be.
What was the early
goals of chemists?
What were they trying to do?
And one of the
things that they did
is they took things like
a rock and say, well,
how do you break this down?
What's it made of?
And so they smash it, or
they light stuff on fire.
We don't tell our students
to do that, by the way.
Or they mix things
together to smash it.
They break it.
They mix it with that.
And they say,
well, what happens?
And through that came
discovery of the basic building
blocks of matter.
And so what I wanted
is I wanted to say,
well, OK, let's put ourselves
back in that position.
At the time, my
youngest daughter was 6.
And so she had had something
like three birthday parties
she went to in one weekend.
And so our hallway had a whole
bunch of these goody bags
with candy and Disney toys.
And I'd look at those and think
maybe we could put chemistry
in these bags.
So we created a set of goody
bags, about one each week.
And so in the very
first goody bag,
I give students five
different strips of something.
I don't tell them what they are.
And I give them a ruler
to measure the strips.
They can weigh them.
And I give them some vinegar.
And again, the idea is to try
to put them in the position of,
well, let me give
you things that you
don't know what they are.
How would you figure that out?
And then gets to a
really important part
of the goody bag, it
is meant to complement
what I'm teaching by
giving a way for them
to touch and hold and
interact with the chemistry,
but it's also meant
for them if they
want to go beyond
what we're learning
and to try their own ideas out.
SARAH HANSEN: Professor
Grossman knows
his methods aren't
exactly conventional
and might not even be effective
in every given scenario.
But his teaching
experiments are guided
by strong communication
with his students
and a simple yet
powerful philosophy--
trust the process.
JEFFREY GROSSMAN: You don't
have to have everything work
perfectly.
But work on it together
with your students.
So the goody bags, I was
very excited about them.
But I think they really
needed to be tried for a year
and then to figure out
well, OK, what worked
and what didn't work?
And let me get feedback.
And let me talk to
students about it.
And then let's make them better.
And I think that's
true every year.
I always want to teach better.
And I always want to
get feedback and realize
what doesn't work and what
does and then amplify what does
and add to it.
And trying new ideas out
is a part of that process.
I tell my students all
the time that success--
this is so important.
Progress has nothing at all
to do with success, nothing.
Progress has to do
with what we choose
to do with failure
because that is
then what leads to the success.
And I try to convey
that to students.
And I have to
convey it to myself
as well, that you have to
remind ourselves that we're
all in that same position.
SARAH HANSEN: And so
Professor Grossman
continues to work on
inspiring his students
to explore new ways of
looking at the world one goody
bag at a time.
He's made all of his
teaching materials
from Introduction to
Solid State Chemistry
openly available to you on our
MIT OpenCourseWare website.
So be sure to check them out.
Thank you for listening.
We hope you're
feeling as excited
as we are to keep learning.
We'd love to hear how you
use the resources on MIT
OpenCourseWare to power change
in your life, classroom,
or community.
You can send us an email or even
call us to tell us your story.
And we'll share it
with other listeners
so they can feel inspired too.
Our phone number
is 617-475-0534.
And you can also find
it in the show notes.
Signing off from
Cambridge, Massachusetts,
I'm Sarah Hansen from
MIT OpenCourseWare.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHILD: Ma, "pah-k" the "cah."